we've seen over the last week mr speaker
this unworkable shameful and desperate
attempt to distract
from the prime minister's law breaking
that the home secretary should not go
along with because she is undermining
not just respect for the rule of law but
also her office by providing cover for
him the policies that she has announced
today
are unworkable unethical and
extortionate in the cost for the british
taxpayer
there's no information from the home
secretary about the costs today will she
admit the 120 million she's announced
doesn't pay for a single person to be
transferred she hasn't actually got an
agreement on the price for each person
in fact the 120 million pounds is the
eye-watering price the home office is
paying just for a press release so
what's the rest of the cost what is the
year's this year's budget how many
people will it cover the home office has
briefed it might be 30 000 pounds per
person to cover up to three months
accommodation but that is already three
times more than the ordinary cost of
dealing with an asylum case in the uk
and her statement says she's going to
provide five years of cost well in
australia
offshoring costs 1.7 million pounds per
person that is over a hundred times more
than the ordinary asylum cost from here
so where is all the money going to come
from in order to fund this plan the only
she says she's going to save money on
hotels but the only reason we're paying
a fortune in hotel costs is because the
home office decision making has totally
collapsed
are only taking 14 000 as initial asylum
decisions a year that is half what they
were doing five years ago half taking
fewer decisions than belgium netherlands
austria never mind france and germany so
the cost to the uk taxpayer have soared
by hundreds of millions of pounds
because she isn't capable of taking the
basic asylum decisions and because she's
not capable of taking those decisions
she's trying to pay rwanda to take those
decisions instead whether people are
refugees or not whether they are victims
of modern slavery or not whether they
have family in the uk whether they've
come from afghanistan syria or even
ukraine she is asking them to do the job
that she is not capable she says it will
deter boats and traffickers but the
permanent secretary says otherwise he
says there's no evidence of a deterrent
effect and there has been a total
failure to crack down on criminal gangs
that are at the heart of this problem
the prosecutions for human trafficking
for non-sexual exploitation are down
from 59 in 2015 to just two in 2020 just
two well the criminals won't be deterred
because someone they exploited was sent
to rwanda they don't give money back
guarantees which means they lose money
if their victims end up somewhere else
instead they will just spin more lies
and she is totally failing to crack down
on those criminal gangs so why not get
on with her basic job instead properly
cut down on human traffickers do the
serious work with france and belgium to
prevent the boat setting off instead she
didn't even mention in this statement
and make decisions fast the home or
secretary is just using this policy to
distract from years of failure she
promised three years ago to halve the
number of crossings and instead they
have increased tenfold and this will
make it worse for trafficking the top
police chief and modern slavery
commissioner has said her legislation
will make it harder to prosecute
traffickers when israel tried paying
rwanda to take refugees and asylum
seekers a few years ago independent
reports showed it increased people
smuggling and increased the action of
the criminal gangs and that is the
damage she is doing she is making it
easier for the criminal gangs and harder
for those who need support at a time
when people across our country have come
forward to help those who are fleeing
ukraine to help desperate refugees
instead of working properly with other
countries the home secretary is doing
the opposite all she is doing is making
it easier for the criminal gangs so will
she tell us the facts the real costs of
this policy the real damage it's going
to do to human trafficking and people
smugglers and come clean with the public
and come clean with the house
home secretary
mr speaker well mr speaker i should just
say that response was just somewhat
highly predictable
if i may say so and i think it's
important just to say to everyone in the
house right now you cannot put a price
on saving human lives
[Applause]
and mr speaker if i may the lady was a
minister in the blair government when
the powers that have given this
government to undertake the legal basis
of this policy were introduced um back
then and i don't remember the current
home secretary shadow home secretary
exploding in this in this synthetic rage
when she occupied a seat in the blair
government when all those policies were
put in action and those mr speaker were
acts passed in 1999 2002 2004 for
partnerships in this similar way by the
way the same partnerships and that were
used to put in place the dublin
regulations to return inadmissible
asylum seekers to eu member states and
of course the honourable lady has gone
on the record multiple times to attack
the government for leaving those
regulations while at the same time
calling for a replacement to be put in
place now she's attacking the government
for using the very powers that only a
few weeks ago she was saying that we
still could be using if we hadn't left
the eu
i think quite frankly mr speaker what
we've seen today from the party opposite
and from the honourable lady is quite
frankly their absolute inability to
understand this issue this
differentiation between legal migration
and illegal migration they should be
honest about their policies their
position is to stand for open borders
and uncontrolled immigration
and mr speaker if i may just go even
further i mean she speaks about the
policy being unworkable and then
extortionate well if the policy is
unworkable it can't then be extortionate
because we'll be making payments based
on delivery and this is the point about
our scheme that there is nothing that
she has said today that actually puts an
alternative forward that actually seeks
to deal with the issue of people
trafficking um deaths in the channel and
importantly i think the labour party
being exposed today for having no policy
no ideas to stop people smuggling yeah